everything because I mean I'm so old we
used to take a shower in our uniform
because you know when we because we flew
commercial my first time out there's no
error where you did yes it is stop
you're making this up no I'm not there's
no way that you you were supposed to
wash your
uniforms
no one in the right mind is never done
nothing let them finish
and soap they give you soap no no no
when I first got to the NBA we flew
commercial yes
exactly Gonna Get You get your arm clean
you had to wash your uniform yourself so
after the game when you got to your room
you took a shower in your uniform and
dried and dropped on on the commercial
airline the next one
you had to let him finish yeah if you
ever heard this in your life well how
are y'all cleaning y'all uniform y'all
playing in funky universe
when you're flying the next morning you
can clean your uniform without showering
in it well that is that is that is
possible you can actually clean it
without showering you don't have to have
it all yeah no no but it's easier to do
it that way
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]